tonight you will hear Margolies shudder
lead author of hidden figures the
American Dream in the untold story of
the black women mathematicians who
helped win the space race share her
journey about writing this remarkable
story that combines the rich
intersection of the civil rights era the
space race the Cold War and the movement
for gender equality
so as an anthropologist with an
operation for history I was curious
about this date September 8 what
happened with NASA on this date so
September 8th 1967 the surveyor 5
launched September 8th 1983 SATCOM 7
launched September 8th 2000 sts-106
launched and today September 8 2016
Margo Lee said early publicly launches
her book getting figures into the
literary world
[Music]
so a little bit on Margo I know many of
you know her or went to school with her
heard someone of the museum saying that
they wanted a tennis team with her in
high school and that they couldn't wait
to see her again Margo was born and
raised right here in Hampton Virginia
she attended Phoebus high school and
graduated from the University of
Virginia with a degree in finance a
journalist independent researcher
entrepreneur and co-creator of an
english-language monthly magazine inside
Mexico with her husband Aaron Margo is
the daughter of one of the first NASA
black male engineers so she grew up
knowing many of the women in hidden
figures Margo is the founder of a
human-computer project and Alfred P
sloan Foundation fellow and the
recipient of a Virginia foundation of
the humanities grant for her research
into the history of women in computing
she lives in Charlottesville Virginia
writer Virginia Woolf once said that
Anonymous is history anonymous in
history was usually a woman let me say
that again anonymous in history was
usually a woman well tonight these
brilliant women are anonymous no more
thanks to Margo and her book hidden
figures may the names of Katherine G
Johnson
Dorothy Vaughan Mary Jackson dr.
Christine Darden and the other women who
contributed to the space race and
changed the course of history finally
received their do now Lucy gave a few
housekeeping notes I just want to remind
everyone that her talk is going to be
here with the book signing will take
place at the Hampton History Museum
afterwards in the Great Hall okay so
walk back across the street and so
c-span asked me to say that because
they're filming they asked for no flash
photography so if you want to take a
picture just turn your flash off and
please remember to silence your phones
so again I welcome you on behalf of the
Hampton History Museum and they invite
you to make history with us and tonight
Margo is doing just that making history
it is with great pleasure and honor that
I introduce my friend Amiga Margo Lee
shut early
[Applause]
Sidra thank you so much for that amazing
introduction thank you to the Hampton
History Museum which has been incredibly
supportive of this research since the
very beginning
and I can't think of any place better to
publicly launch this endeavor than here
in Hampton Virginia my hometown with my
home people and thank you so much for
coming out here tonight it's it's
actually sort of a wonderful thing that
this this venue this the speech done
giving now is is taking place here at
st. John's in a church because it really
started six years ago
also in a church here in downtown
Hampton First Baptist Church where my
home church where I grew up and I was
sitting in a pew with my parents Robert
and Margaret Lee who are here and my
husband Aaron Chatterley and we were
interviewing a former sunday-school
teacher of mine mrs. Kathleen land about
her career as a mathematician at the
Langley Research Center none of us had
an idea at the time that that first
interview would turn into all of this
this hidden figures the book my first
book and a movie but it's exciting as
it's been to receive that level of
enthusiasm for this endeavor the most
gratifying thing for me about these last
few years has been learning about my
hometown there was so much that I didn't
know and so much that I didn't know
about the people who lived here the
people who I knew growing up here so
writing this book for me has been a way
of telling my story and tracing my path
from the lives of these groundbreaking
women this is my history this is your
history this history belongs to all of
us the thrilling parts the mundane parts
the hard parts and the painful parts all
of this has
who we are today and so the fact that we
are here in this church across from the
Hampton History Museum which sponsored
this event there were so close to
Hampton University to the Langley
Research Center to Fort Monroe to the
archaeological remains of the grand
contraband camp which is the first
autonomous black settlement in the
United States it simply couldn't be a
more fitting venue hidden figures
follows the lives of four
african-american women
Dorothy Vaughan Mary Jackson Katherine
Johnson and Christine Darden it was here
[Music]
I am so pleased also to let you know
that many of the family members of
Dorothy Vaughn and Mary Jackson and I
believe mrs. Johnson are here as well as
Gloria champagne who was a part of my
book and many other women who worked
with them and men who worked with them
over the Langley Research Center so um
thank you so much for coming and if you
see them in the crowd tonight definitely
I think I see Sharon stack back there
I'm just so thrilled that these women
who actually wrote live the history so I
could write it are here so yes so many
of us gathered here we knew these women
we were raised by them or lived with
them or worshiped with them or
socialized with them were taught by them
or worked with them and I'm sure you'll
agree with me when you say that we have
learned a tremendous amount from them so
many lessons from these women from their
lives and I I have you know a list that
could fill another book with the things
that I have learned from them
researching their lives but one of the
most timely I think and and the one that
I just like to emphasize tonight is the
following
never allow fear to get the best of
curiosity and imagination sending humans
into space is an inherently risky
endeavor it takes a powerful imagination
to believe that it's possible to land
humans on the moon and to bring them
back safely
but that adventure one of humanity's
greatest had its roots right here in
Hampton Virginia that a black woman
could do some of the calculations to get
them there given the time that might
have taken even more imagination to to
come to fruition but that happened as
well as we know from the acclaim that
our own Katherine Johnson has received
from the work that she did on the
mercury and Apollo missions most notably
on John Glenn's groundbreaking orbital
flight in nineteen
sixty-two people from around the around
the United States indeed from around the
world came to work at Langley these
women worked alongside people of all
backgrounds and they achieved together
things that even today 47 years later we
have to stop and marvel it's incredible
what is possible when you take the best
minds among us and allow their
imaginations to run free so the
narrative of hidden figures is told
through the eyes of these four
african-american women who is also my
mission to use the stories of their
lives to tell a series of other stories
of World War two how it transformed our
city and our society as the anxious days
of the Cold War of the hope and the
conflict of the civil rights movement
and of the great strides that all women
have made legally socially and
economically over the course of the 20th
century scores of black women worked as
mathematicians at Langley and at the
other NASA installations around the
country there were so many names sue
Wilder Eunice Smith Barbara Holly
christine ricci Ida Bassett Miriam man
Irma times any easly Catherine Petry oh
there were so many of them more than I
could ever include in the book but those
women were part of a larger cohort of
women white women like Virginia Tucker
Marjorie Hannah Dorothy Lee Farah Huckle
Sharon stack sarah.billick Mary shut
Burton barber Weigel and these women
just like the West computers for
valedictorians they were math and
science competition winners they were
very smart women who until they came to
Langley thought that they would put
their math degrees to work in a
classroom they too have received a
fraction of the credit that they deserve
in the 1970s and 1980s black women like
Mary Jackson and Janet McKenzie worked
together with white Langley colleagues
like Gloria champagne and
hats and Belinda Adams to create
opportunities for talented women of all
backgrounds through an organization that
I started called the human-computer
project I'm trying to recover the names
of all of the women who worked as
computers mathematicians and engineers
during the early days of the NACA and
NASA not just it Langley but at all of
the NASA and NACA installations over the
years so tonight I just like to
encourage you to get in touch with me
there's a contact form on my website
Margeaux the shed early comm you can I
get in touch with the museum but if you
know the names of women who were your
grandmother's or mothers aunts
colleagues friends ladies that you knew
from church you're your neighbors please
let me know because I really would like
to have all of their names so none of
these women are in the shadows anymore
now all good stories have a beginning a
middle and an end and I already knew the
end I'm the result of this wonderful
history that happened here in Hampton
Virginia
my father is retired like NASA Langley
research scientist my mother is retired
Hampton University English professor I'm
the proud product of integrated Hampton
city schools and I graduated from the
University of Virginia which now accepts
men and women from all backgrounds
at that first meeting with Miss Lance
six years ago led me to ask the question
how did this all begin
how did she and Katherine Johnson and
the many other women that I remember
from my childhood end up working at NASA
of all places many people know the story
of the space program which was gaining
momentum at a time at the same time that
a young preacher from Atlanta Atlanta
named Martin Luther King jr. was taking
center stage and what was then becoming
known as the civil rights movement but
fewer people know that well before the
start of the space program
Hampton was America's first center for
aeronautical research and development
fewer people know that before dr. King a
civil rights leader named a philip
randolph led a campaign to ban
discrimination in the civil service and
the defense industries against
african-americans something that also
benefited Mexicans Jews Catholics many
other people who had been left out of
the new jobs that were coming about as a
result of World War two in May 1943
almost two years after Franklin
Roosevelt's executive order
desegregating the civil service five
black women started jobs working as
mathematicians at the Langley Memorial
aeronautical laboratory so what I'd like
to do right now is read from the first
chapter of my book hidden figures this
is how the story begins and as I'm
reading remember it all happens here in
Hampton Virginia
chapter one a door opens Melvin Butler
the personnel officer at the Langley
Memorial aeronautical laboratory had a
problem the scope and nature of which
was made plain Anna night may 1943
telegram - the Civil Services chief of
field operations this establishment has
urgent need for approximately 100 junior
physicists and mathematicians 100
assistant computers 75 minor laboratory
apprentices 125 helper trainees 30
scenographer x' and typists exclaimed
the missive every morning at 7 a.m. the
bow-tied butler and his staff sprang to
life dispatching the lab station wagon
to the local rail Depot to the bus
station and the ferry terminal to
collect the men and women so many women
now each day more women who had made
their way to the lonely finger of land
on the Virginia coast the shuttle
conveyed the recruits to the door of the
laboratory service building on the
campus of Langley field upstairs butler
staff which whisked them through the
first-day stations forms photos and the
oath of office I will support and defend
the Constitution of the United States
against all enemies foreign and domestic
so help me God
thus installed the newly minted civil
servants fanned out to take their places
in one of the research facilities
expanding inventory of buildings each
already full as a pod right with peace
no sooner had Sherwood Butler the
laboratories had a procurement set the
final brick on a new building than his
brother Melvin said about filling it
with new employees closets and hallways
stock rooms and workshops stood in as
makeshift offices someone came up with
the bright idea of putting two desks
head-to-head and jury-rigging the new
piece of furniture with a jump seat in
order to squeeze three workers into
space designed for two
in the four years since since Hitler's
troops overran Poland since American
interest and the European war converged
in all-consuming conflict the
laboratories complement of five hundred
odd employees at the close of the decade
was on its way to 1500 yet the great
Groening war machine swallowed them
whole and remained hungry for more the
offices of the administration building
looked out on the crushing
crescent-shaped airfield only the flow
of civilian clothes people heading to
the laboratory the oldest outpost of the
National Advisory Committee for
Aeronautics NACA distinguished Loeb
brick buildings belonging to that agency
from identical ones used by the US Army
Air Corps the two installations had
grown up together the airbase devoted to
the development of America's military
airpower capability the laboratory a
civilian agency charged with advancing
the scientific understanding of
aeronautics and disseminating its
findings to the military and to private
industry since the beginning the army
since beginning the army had allowed the
laboratory to operate on the campus of
the airfield the close relationship with
the army fliers served as a constant
reminder to the engineers that every
experiment they conducted had real-world
implications the double hangar 210
footlong building standing side by side
had been covered in camouflage paint in
1942 to deceive enemy eyes in search of
targets it's shady and cavernous
interior sheltering the machines and
their minders from the elements men in
canvas jumpsuits often in groups moved
in trucks and jeeps from plane to plane
stopping to hover at this one or that
one
like pollinating insects checking them
filling them with gas replacing parts
examining them becoming one with them
and taking off for the heavens the music
of airplane engines and propellers
cycling through the various movements of
takeoff flight and landing played from
before sunrise until dusk each machine
sound as unique to its minders
babies cry to its mother beneath the
tenner notes of the engines played the
bass war of the laboratories wind
tunnels turning there on domaine demand
hurricanes onto the plains plane parts
model planes full-sized planes just two
years prior with stormcloudsgathering
President Roosevelt challenged the
nation to ramp up its production of
airplanes to 50,000 per year it seemed
an impossible task for an industry that
as recently as 1938 had only provided
the Army Air Corps with 90 planes a
month now America's aircraft industry
was a production miracle easily
surpassing Roosevelt's mark by more than
half it had become the largest industry
in the world the most productive the
most sophisticated out producing the
Germans by more than three times and the
Japanese by nearly five the facts were
clear to all belligerence the final
conquest would come from the sky for the
Flyboys of the Air Corps airplanes
through mechanisms for transporting
troops and supplies to combat zones
armed wings for pursuing enemies
sky-high launching pads for ships
sinking bombs they reviewed their
vehicles in an exhaustive pre-flight
check out before climbing into the sky
mechanics rolled up their sleeves and
sharpened their eyes a broken piston an
improperly locked shoulder harness a
faulty fuel tank light any one of these
could cost lives but even before the
plane responded to its pilots knowing
caressed its nature its very DNA from
the shape of its wings to the cowling of
its engines had been manipulated refined
massaged deconstructed and recombined by
the engineers next door
long before America's aircraft
manufacturers placed one of their newly
conceived flying machines into
production
they sent a working prototype to the
Langley laboratory so that design could
be tested and improved nearly every high
performance aircraft model in the United
States made its way to the
here in Hampton Virginia for drag
cleanup the engineers parked the planes
in the wind tunnels making note of air
disturbing surfaces loaded fuselages
uneven wing geometries as prudent and
thorough as old family doctors they
examined every aspect of the air flowing
over the plane making careful note of
the vital signs NACA test pilots
sometimes with an engineer riding
shotgun took the blame plane for a
flight did it roll and expectedly
did it stall was it hard to manoeuvre
resisting the pilot like a shopping cart
with a bad wheel the engineers subjected
that airplanes to tests capturing and
analyzing the numbers recommending
improvement some slight others
significant even small improvements in
speed and efficiency multiplied over
millions of pilot miles added up to a
difference that could tip the long-term
'[ __ ] balance of the war and the Allies
favored victory through air power
Henry Reid engineer in charge of the
Langley laboratory crooned to his
employees the Shibboleth the reminder of
the importance of the airplane to the
wars outcome victory through airpower
the NASA it's repeated to each other
minding each decimal point poring over
differential equations and pressure
distribution charts until their eyes
tired and the Battle of research victory
would be theirs
unless of course melvin Butler failed to
feed the three shifts the day six days a
week operation with fresh minds the
engineers are one thing but each
engineer required the support of a
number of others craftsmen to build the
airplane models test in the tunnels
mechanics to maintain the tunnels and
nimble number crunchers to process the
numerical deluge that issued from the
research lift and drag fiction in flow
what was a plane but a bundle of physics
physics of course meant math and math
MIT mathematicians and since the middle
of the last decade mathematicians had
meant women Langley's first female
computing poles started in 1935 had
caused an uproar among the men at the
laboratory how could a female
mind process something so rigorous and
precise as math the very idea investing
five hundred dollars on a calculating
machine so it could be used by a girl
but the girls had been good very good
better at computing in fact the many of
the engineers the men themselves
grudgingly admitted with only a handful
of girls winning the title mathematician
a professional designation that put them
on equal footing with entry-level male
employees the fact that most computers
were designated as lower price lower
paid sub professionals provided a boost
to the laboratories bottom line but in
1943 the girls were harder to come by
Virginia Tucker Langley's head computer
ran laps up and down the East Coast
searching for coeds with even a modicum
of analytical or mechanical skill hoping
for matriculating college students to
fill the hundreds of open positions for
computers scientific aides model makers
laboratory assistants and yes even
mathematicians she conscripted what
seemed like entire classes of math
graduates from her North Carolina alma
mater the Greensboro College for women
and she hunted at Virginia schools like
Sweet Briar in Lynchburg and the State
Teachers College in Farmville
Melvin Butler lived a leaned on the u.s.
Civil Service Commission and the war
manpower Commission as hard as he could
so the laboratory might get top priority
on the limited pool of qualified
applicants he penned ads for the local
newspaper The Daily Press reduce your
household duties women who are not
afraid to roll up their sleeves and do
jobs previously filled by men should
call the Langley Memorial aeronautical
laboratory read one notice fervent pleas
from the personnel department were
published in the employee newsletter
airscrew are there members of your
family or others you know who would like
to play a part in gain gaining supremacy
of the air have you friends of either
sex who would like to do important work
toward winning and shortening the war
with men being absorbed
until the military services with women
already in demand by eagle and eager
employers the labor market was as
exhausted as the war workers themselves
a bright spot presented itself in the
form of another man's problem a philip
Randolph the head of the largest black
labor union in the country demanded that
roosevelt open lucrative war jobs to
Negro applicants threatening in the
summer of 1941 to bring 100,000 Negroes
to the nation's capital in protest if
the president rebuffed this demand who
the hell is this guy Randolph whew
Joseph rau the president's aide
Roosevelt blinked at all courtly black
man with Shakespearean diction and the
stare of an eagle ASA Phillip Randolph
close friend of Eleanor Roosevelt headed
the 35,000 strong Brotherhood of
sleeping car porters the porters waited
on passengers in the nation's segregated
trains daily enduring prejudice and
humiliation from whites nevertheless
these jobs were coveted in the black
community because they provided a
measure of economic stability and social
standing believing that civil rights
were inextricably linked to economic
rights
Randolph fought tirelessly for the
rights of Negro Americans to participate
fairly and the wealth of the country
they had helped build twenty years in
the future Randolph would address the
multitudes at another march on
Washington then concede the stage to a
young charismatic minister from Atlanta
named Martin Luther King jr. later
generations would associate the black
freedom movement with King's name but in
1941 as the United States oriented every
aspect of its society toward war for the
second time in less than 30 years
it was Randolph's long-term vision and
the specter of a march that never
happened that prior to open the door
that had been closed like a Bank fault
since the end of Reconstruction with two
strokes of a pen executive order 8802
ordering the desegregation
the defense industry an executive order
9:34 six creating the Fair Employment
Practices committee to monitor the
national project of economic inclusion
Roosevelt primed the pump for a new
source of flavor to come into the tight
production process nearly two years
after Randolph's 1941 showdown as the
laboratories personnel request
reached the civil service applicants
have qualified Negro female candidates
began filtering in to the Langley
Service building presenting themselves
for consideration by the laboratories
personnel staff no photo at five does to
the applicants color that requirement
instituted on the under the
administration of Woodrow Wilson was
trucked down as the Roosevelt
administration tried to dismantle
discrimination and hiring practices but
the applicants alma mater z' tipped
their hand
West Virginia State University Howard
Arkansas agriculture agricultural
mechanical and Norma normal Hampton
Institute just across town all Negro
schools nothing in the applications
indicated anything less than fitness for
the job if anything they came to the job
with more experience than the white
women applicants after having had many
years of teaching experience on top of
math and science degrees they would need
a separate space Melvin Butler Melvin
Butler knew then they would have to
point someone to head the new group an
experienced girl white obviously someone
whose dispositions suited the
sensitivity of the assignment the
warehouse building a brand new space on
the west side of the laboratory a part
of campus that was still more wilderness
than anything resembling a workplace
could be just the thing his further
Sherwood's group had already moved there
as had some of the employees in the
personnel department with
round-the-clock pressure to test the
airplanes queued up in the hangar
engineers would welcome the additional
hands so many of the engineers were
northerners relatively agnostic on the
racial issue but devout when it came to
mathematical talent
Melvin Butler himself hailed from
Portsmouth just across the bay from
Hampton
required no imagination on this part to
guess what some of his fellow Virginians
might think of the idea of integrating
Negro women into Langley's offices to
come here's as the Virginians called the
newcomers to the state and their strange
ways be damned there had always been
Negro employees in the lab janitors
cafeteria workers mechanics assistants
ground keepers but opening the door to
Negroes who would be professional peers
that was something new Butler proceeded
with discretion no big announcement in
the Daily Press no fanfare and air scoop
but he also had proceeded with direction
nothing to Herald the arrival of the
Negro women to the laboratory but
nothing to derail their arrival either
maybe Melvin Butler was progressive for
his time in place or maybe it was just a
functionary carrying out his duty maybe
he was both state law and Virginia
custom kept him from truly progressive
action but perhaps the promise of a
segregated office it was just the cover
he needed to get the black women and the
door a Trojan horse of segregation
opening the door to integration whatever
his personal feelings on race one thing
was clear Butler was a Langley man
through and through loyal to the
laboratory to its mission to its
worldview and to its charge during the
war by nature and by mandate he and the
rest of the NACA were all about
practical solutions so too was a Phillip
Randolph the leaders and the fatigue of
all activism unrelenting pressure and
superior organizing skills lay the
foundation for what in the 1960s would
come to be known as a civil rights
movement but there is no way that
Randolph or the men at the laboratory
where anyone else could have predicted
that the hiring of a group of black
female mathematicians at the Langley
Memorial aeronautical laboratory would
end at the moon still shrouded from view
were the great aeronautical advances
that would crush the notion that faster
than sound flight was a physical
impossibility the electronic calculating
devices that would amplify the power of
science and technology to unthinkable
dimensions no one anticipated
millions of wartime women would refuse
to leave the American workplace and
forever changed the meaning of women's
work or that American Negroes would
persist in their demand for full access
to the founding ideals of their country
and not be moved the black female
mathematicians who walked into Langley
in 1943 would find themselves at the
intersection of these great
transformations their sharp minds and
ambitions contributing to what the
United States would consider one of its
greatest victories but in 1943 America
existed in the urgent present responding
to the needs of the here and now Butler
took the next step making a note to add
another item to sure with seemingly end
of endless requisition lists a metal
bathroom sign bearing the words colored
girls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so that's how the story begins I won't
tell you everything about the story
except that the Americans finally do get
to the moon
but everything that happens in between
hopefully you'll enjoy reading that and
so I thought it might be interesting to
open the floor to any questions that
that you might have at this time
yes oh yeah I'm sorry if you guys could
if you could raise your hand and then
the microphone will come to you so we
can hear you Lag women well the thing
about the civil service is to pay
depending on your grade so if you were
hired in as a GS four then you know you
would get paid what the other Chia's
forested the issue was getting hired
into that level so it wasn't always the
case that the black women were hired in
at the same level though there were
actually in the very beginning some
women such as Dorothy Vaughn who was
hired in at a p1 level which was
equivalent of many male engineers so if
there were there were definitely
exceptions but in general most of the
women black white or otherwise were
hired as sub professionals and paid less
than men
[Music]
yes I can just talk Marco I am so
fascinated by your research and your
productivity I'm gonna buy two books I
had a question about the book we could
not fail by moss and Paul you were able
to read use that too okay because I'm
just finding some fascinating things
about them how George Carruthers the
black guy who actually did all his
sophisticated inventions of the camera
that allowed us to see pictures of the
moon and I'm just so proud of you okay
thank you yeah there's there's a book
that came out last year that was called
we could not fail and it tells the story
of many of the african-american
engineers who worked at the Marshall
Space Center there's also a book that
came out called rise of the rocket girls
which tells the story of a group of
women who worked at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory which is now part of Langley
or part of NASA out in Pasadena
California during World War two so I
think it's really exciting that a lot of
these stories of people who have worked
in the space program and worked in
aeronautics for a very long time are
starting to come to light right now and
that that's another book that that tells
that story
hi Margo I too am very proud but when
you were writing the book of researching
it what was the one if you can think of
it most surprising anecdote or nugget
that you came across in these stories
there were so many like there were just
there were just so many you know for
example there was a there was a Cold War
tie to Langley here there was an
engineer who had worked here at Langley
and I think he left in 1946 to go to the
Ames Laboratory but he was connected
with the famous Rosenberg spy case if
you remember during the Cold War
the Rosenbergs were executed for spying
for the Russians and a engineer who had
worked here at Langley was actually put
on trial and he was he was convicted of
perjury but they had the the government
charged him with passing NACA secrets to
the Russians and so you know the
research on that was fascinating because
the FBI came to Hampton they knocked on
people's doors you know they were
investigating this whole situation
thinking that people were communists so
that that was another very surprising
link that Hampton Virginia had to you
know this great global struggle between
the United States and the Russians
on the steps behind you
what's the riskiest thing you've done or
kind of parallel to that would you be
brave enough to go into space also would
you be an astronaut if you didn't have
to do any other homework but you could
just go based on all the math that's
been done before us the question the
question was would I want to go into
space
[Music]
I I kind of really like the Earth's I'm
not sure that I've ever although I I
must say that I think I really do think
the work that NASA does and is
continuing to do is really important and
I think that it's interesting and very
exciting that right now NASA is taking
up the mantle and pushing forward to go
to Mars I think that's really exciting
one of the other things is they're
resurrecting some of the work that was
pioneered by Christine Darden in terms
of supersonic transport planes I think
that's great that's happening right here
at Langley so you know I might not be
the first passenger on for Mars one but
you know I think the fact that that work
is continuing is very important and very
very exciting how did you go from finish
in the book to the movie how did that
happen
well that that is a very that is a very
interesting question the thing about
this project is from the very beginning
people have responded to it very
strongly and with a great deal of
enthusiasm which is completely has to do
with the strength of the women of all of
the women of the fact that there were so
many women that this wasn't a story of
one woman or even five women but that
there was this group of scores of black
women and that the total group of women
I think was probably from the 1930s to
the 1980s Livesay was more than a
thousand so I think that the idea that
this disproves anything that we know
about women not being able to do math
it's it's it's it's just a natural that
people will respond to it so but and
what happened is my my literary agent
after finding a publisher for the book
got the book proposal into the hands of
a producer who saw it and just was blown
away by the fact that she hadn't heard
this story and ever since you know it's
i've been running to catch up since then
it's been going on kind of a parallel
track and the thing that is is so
exciting for me about that is that i am
so happy that there is so much
enthusiasm for the book and but i know
that there will be an even greater
audience for this history because of
this movie so it's but it's been it's
been a ride for sure
[Music]
after World War two many women in
industry were let go to make room for
returning servicemen to what extent did
that happened at Langley and was there
differential between whites and
african-americans and did some women
continue on and have successful careers
at Langley and rise up through the ranks
and responsibilities
yeah so I it was really interesting I
had access to all of the employee
newsletters from 1942 through the
present and the newsletters were
constantly reporting what was happening
in terms of recruiting in terms of the
reduction in force the best I can tell
right after the war there was a cutback
slated at Langley but at the end of the
day they made a cut of only 30 employees
it seemed enough people after the war
returned home you know left their jobs
that they only had to cut 30 people but
then in the next 12 months you know 18
months something like that they started
recruiting again and looking
particularly for more women to do the
computing and so that really coincided
like 1946 1947 with commands in the army
being consolidated at Fort Monroe
command being consolidated at at Langley
the Norfolk Naval Base so this entire
region after the war there was a lot of
speculation that like after World War
one this area would go through a
tremendous depression and so I you know
I saw so many newspaper articles of
people speculating and being concerned
about that and what happened is that you
know the Cold War started and Hampton
Roads turned into one of the center
of what we call the military-industrial
complex at which lasted for a very long
time so and Langley went along with that
with that boom it did not seem for my
the research that I did that there was a
differential in the layoffs between the
white women and the black women and the
word seem to get around even after you
know the peak of World War two and a lot
of black churches and the lounge's of
black high schools that there was this
amazing job and Newsom Park that there
was this job opening for black women at
Langley who had math degrees let me say
congratulations and again I know mom and
dad are proud as I spoke to your mom
we're all very proud have you gotten a
chance to view the whole movie and my
question is if you have is it faction or
is it accurate because I'm in
I'm a historian and when people see
things on the screen they often take it
as the gospel truth so I need to know
what I'm looking for
yeah that's the question everybody wants
to know I haven't seen the whole movie
they're still working on it they're
they're working on record time because
you know they're they're excited about
it and they want to make sure that it's
it's in the theaters definitely by
January and possibly kind of early
previews in December so they are they're
still working on it you know the thing
for me working on the book and the movie
at the same time is I kind of had to let
go of the fact that I was writing a
nonfiction book that took place over 30
years of history versus a movie that had
to get people into the theaters tell the
story capture the essence of it you know
hit the highlights get in the space and
then come back home safely in two hours
so you know so and I and I've you know
I've talked pretty closely with you know
the people who are the producers of the
movie and you know in the beginning I
really had a hard time kind of
understanding well you know you
basically can't film a book and put it
in the movie and sell movie tickets so
the movie is inspired by true events you
know they obviously have to take a
segment of the history and then making
it make it exciting and what they
decided to do was to focus on that time
in from Sputnik when you know where the
Russians first launched the Sputnik
satellite and you know sending the US
and the and the the Soviets into the the
Cold War the space race until that
moment when Katherine Johnson reviews
the calculations for John Glenn's fight
so which you know the moment has been
recounted many many times by many people
including mrs. Johnson herself so they
they made the decision which being film
people I think was the right decision to
you know take one of the real highlights
of all of the research and make that the
movie instead of the entire book
first of all I want to congratulate you
in bringing so many people together from
your research I am really happy to be
here because it brings so many people
together in a way that they had no idea
that they were connected because the
Vaughan's Dorothy Vaughan used to serve
dinner and and provide food for starving
students from Hampton Institute and so
who who would have known back then what
she really was all about that she was
this of course we all knew that she was
a smart lady and she raised all of these
amazing children but I'm sitting next to
people who are cannot only connected to
the the people that are in your story
that are in this book but also people
who are connected to you that are
connected to me and this person sitting
next to me and this person sitting over
here and I guarantee you that there are
folks in here that didn't know that they
had a connection with each other had it
not been for your book and your research
so if we just realize that through
conversation through passion for
research and knowing our history and
making that anonymous women we're all
connected so so much we're all so
connected and I just thank you for doing
that
providing another way for us to realize
that we're all really connected that's
the part of your story that rings so
loud and clear from me and I guarantee
you if we asked everybody to raise their
hand who is connected to somebody
because of your book
everybody would raise their hand they're
connected we are connected
[Applause]
[Music]
I just want to thank you also for
bringing us all together we're the
Winston Jackson clan and we've come from
all across the country to help support
you in your book so thank you
and I also wanted to ask will there be a
premiere here in Hampton for the movie
[Music]
that is the question um I I think NASA
has been so supportive of this project I
mean not just from the Langley Research
Center which has been amazing from the
very beginning and I I cannot think them
enough for what they've done for this
and me in this book but the people at
NASA headquarters have also been very
supportive they are very interested in
doing what they can to make sure that
this community which is the core of this
story has the chance to participate and
the excitement you know of that movie
and I've seeing you know seeing that our
friends and neighbors and relatives up
on the screen so I I don't know the
details of that but I do know that
that's something that everyone you know
that that they're very interested in
making sure that this community is is
participating yes my question is I'm
curious the it happened at First Baptist
Church and the discussion or the idea
came into your head when your Sunday
school teacher teacher was mentioned
what specifically that day you know the
light bulb went off oh this is a store
here because if she was just Sunday
school teacher and you worship together
you know growing up you knew her
basically but what word or what happened
that particular Sunday to spark hidden
true
it's something that I write about in the
prologue of my book and it would happen
that you know my husband and I were here
visiting my parents in in December of
2010 and we went to church that Sunday
and met and met and spoke with my former
Sunday school teacher and driving back
home my father was talking about her and
the conversation turned to some of the
other women who had worked at NASA that
he had worked with and
the work that they did and you know and
these were stories that I you know I'd
heard and kind of knew and you know
you're from here you don't really think
about it and but my husband who is not
from here was like wait a minute hold on
like can you please tell me this story
again like this is how come I have never
heard of this story and so I think a lot
of us have that experience of growing up
someplace wherever it is and you take it
for granted you know the the neighbors
and the the talent that's there and the
things that happen and this this was a
case of something happening in this case
it was my husband looking at that and
forcing me to appreciate the community
that I had grown up in and then asking
this question well why were those women
there and that was really what happened
it was as simple as that
[Music]
thank you for writing the book and also
with a new opening of the African
American Museum will you be speaking
there over your book be published me
featured at the book at the bookstore
there and with any of the ladies or any
of you will be at that African American
Museum any time I didn't hear the first
part of your question um what you or the
book or the ladies yes while I be
speaking at the African American Museum
I am still sort of working through a lot
of the details of the of the where I'm
going to be for the Fall and I'm hoping
that that Washington DC and possibly
that venue will be among them
congratulations Margot I know that your
background is in finance and media and
journalism
what was your experience diving into
history this is a question from my
historian friend Jeffrey Harris and the
question is as someone who had a
background in business I mean I studied
finance in college what was my
experience diving into history I really
loved it it was you know I think a lot
of people think that so many of these
things are separate that business is
separate from science is separate from
humanities and that these are all so
different that it's not possible for the
same people to have those interests and
I always thought of myself as somebody
who was Business and Finance and you
know entrepreneurship and the process of
uncovering this story was wonderful it
was so fascinating I love digging in the
archives I loved looking at old
newspaper articles and but a lot of the
skills that I learned working in
business sort of analysis skills and
even writing skills um certainly helped
me a lot in in this process but I I
loved it I loved every minute of it hi
hi I'd never think this is old but I'd
like for you to give us that story with
John Glenn please
so the question the question was
actually a request to recap what's
probably the most well-known anecdote
that has to do with this particular
history and that is in the book that is
certainly an anecdote has been told many
times and you know for the last 50 years
basically about Katherine Johnson and
her role in the the orbital mission
which of John Glenn's flight that really
tipped the balance in the space race
between the United States and the Soviet
Union so as you know for from the the
research here a computer today we think
of as a piece of electronic hardware
well before really the 1950s and 60s in
the advent of these enormous electronic
calculating machines a computer was
somebody who computed and that usually
meant someone who were skirt it was a
woman so when these electronic computers
started coming you know being used more
widely for government applications and
business applications it took a while
for people to trust them to you know
it's any new technology to figure out
how to use them to understand how
reliable they are so for a long time
obviously most of the aeronautical
research and even into the early part of
the space program was done by women the
women in the book women like the women
at the book they they worked at Langley
they lurked it worked at all of the NASA
installations they worked at the bureau
of standards and they were working on
the space program calculating the
trajectories of how are we going to take
this man in
and blast him into space around the
earth so mrs. Johnson worked in a group
called the flight research division
which I think changed its name over the
years but the the people in that
particular division were very closely
linked to the early days of the space
program and she her group was
responsible for calculating those
trajectories of those early flights but
the point at which the the mission
transformed from a simple ballistic
trajectory so send the man up and he
comes back down like that to something
that that really circled the entire
earth required a much higher level of
communications and computer technology
so that NASA Langley was in charge of
building the tracking Network and that
was one of Gloria shampagne's jobs in
the early days working in the mercury
tracking range so setting up these
tracking stations around the earth to in
order to track this man in the spaceship
as he circulated overhead and so
computers were brought in to help with
that task to do that task to calculate
those numbers real time but this was a
real moment at which the old-school
computing which had been done by a
roomful of women sitting at a desk with
$500 calculating machines was handing
off the work to a room computer computer
that took up a room as opposed to a room
full of computers that that would
actually have the computing power
necessary to to track this the satellite
of the earth with the man inside and get
him home safely but as that transition
was happening in mrs. Johnson it was
was you know working in this particular
division among the many many many
checklists as you can imagine that that
NASA had to have to know that this was a
mission that was going to be successful
and as safe as possible
among them was getting Katherine Johnson
who had authored the report in 1959 sort
of laying out the original math
describing these trajectories of how do
you send a man into orbit around the
earth she was asked to compute by hand
the same numbers that the computer the
data that the computer had so
essentially a simulation in which the
woman computed the numbers and she
compared that to what the computer came
up with and if those two different sets
of numbers showed very good agreement
which was the actual word from the the
research report then astronaut John
Glenn was like well you know that's one
of the things that I want to know before
before I go if get the girl to do it
basically
[Music]
because all of the women who work there
at that time were girls that's they were
called girls and so and she was the girl
who worked for those particular brainy
fellas get the girl to do it if the girl
checks the numbers and her numbers check
out with what the computer output says
then you know thumbs up let's go so
that's that is the John Glenn anecdote
and an amazing story as a young person
fascinated by the book in figures I
would like to know what your message to
other young people fascinated with the
book would be
that's there was there so many things I
mean I think you know one of the things
you know that I said earlier this idea
of curiosity and imagination before fear
I think that's that's a really one of
the really important lessons that I
learned from the book another one and
this is something if you ask Katherine
Johnson and you you know you you speak
to her and you say well how is it
possible for you in the South in a work
environment that still had segregated
bathrooms and you know cafeterias and
you know all of these things were still
happening when a woman you know may not
have even been able to get a credit card
in her own name how are you able to do
this work and tell your bosses that you
were you know you were confident that
your math was gonna get this guy into
space and bring him home safely that
seems like a lot to ask and she always
says it goes back to what my father said
to me you are no better than anyone else
and no one is better than you are
[Applause]
and I probably have spent more time
thinking about that than any other thing
that she has said because it's sort of
one of these things that seems very
simple and yet it's one of the most
profound things both the part about no
one is better than you which you know I
think gives us any of us the confidence
to walk into a situation with people who
may be different than we are and to feel
confident that we can hold our head high
but the other part of you are know
better than anyone else that I think is
really the powerful and the the power in
this so Katherine Johnson felt that it
was her prerogative as a black woman in
the still segregated south in this
environment to extend herself to all of
the people she worked with the white
male engineers the white women she
really had such a transcendent sense of
humanity and true equality of meeting
people as equals regardless of who they
were and I think there's there's so many
times when I'm in a situation and I
really do think
well what would Katherine Johnson's
father say about them the thing how
would I employ this you are no better
than anyone else and no one is better
than you because it really it seems very
simple and and she says it as if it were
very simple and it's clearly one of the
keys to her tremendous success and so I
I think that's you know that's that's
another one of the things that I've I
feel like I've learned a lot from doing
this research
one more question yes I know and I know
that you're not gonna be able I don't
think be able to sign all these books so
will you have another time to sign the
books I am definitely going to be back
on the 30th of September at Norfolk
State University so that that will be
another opportunity and it might be I'm
gonna I will talk with the museum and
you know we'll kind of work out to
logistics so that we can get as many
books signed as possible so I think that
is it and I think everyone's so much